él se retiró de la número uno del mundo
del tenis de parís raúl nadie se
esperaba esta noticia la mejor tenista
del mundo la esperanza para volver a
tener a una gran dominadora en el tenis
femenino dice adiós en lo más alto de su
carrera y con sólo 25 años esta
madrugada a silbar y compartió un vídeo
en sus redes sociales en donde explica
que es el momento de perseguir otros
sueños dice que haber ganado wimbledon
del año pasado y haber conquistado el
más reciente abierto de australia es la
manera perfecta de celebrar su carrera
es el segundo retiro de bari ya lo había
hecho en 2014 con 18 años cuando
abandonó la raqueta durante casi dos
años por fatiga a tiempo en el que jugó
cricket de manera profesional en su
tierra natal pero ahora dice que el
sentimiento es otro
ya no tengo el impulso físico el deseo
emocional y un poco todo aquello que
hace falta para desafiarte a ti mismo en
lo más alto del nivel de
drama
creo que sé que estoy absolutamente
vacía físicamente no tengo nada más que
dar
y si para mí eso es el éxito le he dado
todo lo que puedo este hermoso deporte
del tenis y estoy muy feliz por ello
pérez grand slams ha ganado bareiro land
garros wimbledon el abierto de australia
polvo de ladrillos césped y pista rápida
como la 15 títulos en 5 y 12 en dobles
ha sido número uno del mundo durante 121
semanas 114 de ellas de manera
consecutiva la cuarta racha más larga en
la historia del circuito bueno vamos a
ver entonces qué va a pasar si a lo
mejor vuelve pronto juan pero las
reacciones al retiro cuáles han sido
para volver tiene edad pero mientras
tanto simón ale petra kvitova caro bien
la escoba son algunas de las cenizas que
han tenido elogios para barí tras este
anuncio de la elección mero 1 del mundo
de la rama masculina el británico andy
murray también ha tenido palabras para
ella incluso el mismo primer ministro de
australia scott morrison el mandatario
además en resaltó de bario como
embajadora del tenis para los pueblos
indígenas y es que ella tiene orígenes
del pueblo gallego
particularmente quiero decirte gracias
por inspirar a una generación de jóvenes
especialmente una generación de jóvenes
indígenas en este país eres todo clase
de cosas